hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting and fun game uh from round
four or rather it's round two of the ftx
crypto cup it's actually game four of
the match on ichiri versus pagnanda uh
and uh the first three games ended in a
draw there was a lot of uh fight uh
in those three games but in the end no
winner emerged and now this is game four
uh in the last game manish has the white
pieces and it is uh
quite a beautiful game it's a very clean
game so i'm sure you guys are going to
enjoy it as it features the nimso indian
defense so let's dive straight into it
uh and see what happened here uh anish
going into the match uh uh with a loss
from round one he lost to magnus carlsen
and uh
pregnant as you've seen has defeated
alireza firuja so he uh has started this
event with uh with flying colors uh so
let's check it out we have d4 by anish a
knight to f6 c for e6 knight to c3n as
advertised bishop to be for the name so
indian defense is on the board and uh
ponte e3 now now just going for the
standard uh standard line we have
castles and now bishop to d3 the
so-called bishops attack against the
names of indian d5 by prague we have a3
now chasing away the bishop and of
course bishop captures on c3 uh we've
seen some games where white does not
allow the doubling of the c pawn but
we've also seen some games in recent
chess where
white allows it and then uh
well what just gets a beautiful
beautiful game with a lot of attacking
potential so here b captures on c3 d
captures on c for attacking the bishop
bishop captures in just c5 by prague
knight to f3 and now queen to c7
and this is a position that has been
used many many times by many many many
strong players
bishop to e2 usually when we get this
position as of course c captures on d4
is a threat and then the queen will be
attacking the bishop uh you have to move
the bishop so bishop to e2 is one way to
do it bishop to a2 is the other way to
do it bishop to e2 is a safer way bishop
to a2 uh not so safe but maybe a bit
more exciting so here bishop to e2
b6 now preparing to develop the light
square bishop we have bishop to b2 and
now uh this position again has been
reached many many times on the defeated
carlsen from this position carlson
defeated ding from this position and
anish also had this position uh a few
times with the black pieces himself
and usually bishop to b7 is the move
that's played here but i i think prague
prepared incredibly well for this game
and maybe he's even playing a bit of
mind games here uh and he plays c
character sandy for following the game
anish geary played last year in the
super bed classic against wesley so
anish having the black pieces here so
see captures on d4 and now developing
the bishop to a6 offering a trade of
light square bishops with castles by
anish and now in that game that we've
mentioned uh wasteless overs and giri
bishop capture sanity was played but
here prague plays queen to b7 and it is
now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game
so rook to e1 uh anisha continues
development we have bishop capture sunny
to queen captures and not knight b to d7
so i'm sure you guys are wondering
what's the point of the queen on b7 well
it's actually a very very deep idea
prague wants to play b5 he wants the
queen to have
the pawn to have support from the queen
on b7 and then of course he wants to
push b4
much like you would in any other
position as b4 most often wins the game
for either player and then once you
trade off the pawns here then you just
have a past a pawn you push it and you
win the game so here e4 anish grabs the
strong center here uh rook 8 to c8 and
now pawn to h3 we have b5 by prague uh
rook 8 to d1 centralizing the rooks and
pawn to h6 uh leaving the king some uh
breeding room here so you don't get you
know back rank mated uh sometimes in the
future knights to h2 and now pawn to b4
uh prague pushes the pawn and creates a
pass pawn whether it's going to be a
pass b pawn by playing b3 or you will uh
trail of the pawns and then you will
have a past eight pawn so on each traits
here we have captures captures and now
comes uh rook to d3 here uh it's a very
very difficult position for white but uh
if you don't know what to play exactly
uh it's not gonna you know just uh
be completely apparent here you could
play bishop the c1 you could play bishop
to a1 you could reintroduce the knight
into the game with knights to f1 then
bring the knight over to g3 let's say
but anish played rook to d3 and it seems
like a beautiful active move you can
shift the rook into the attack you can
play bishop to a3 attack the queen once
the queen moves you win the rook here
but it is exactly the move that allows
proctor game not maybe the winning
advantage but at least just enough
advantage to push for the win so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the move anish missed and that
allows prague to push for the win
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that by
playing
rook to d3 anisha has basically
blundered a pawn and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
rook to c2 beautiful beautiful move look
at this attacking the queen sacrificing
a full rook or so it seems because if
the rook is captured then you captured
the rook on e1
but it is such a such an elegant move we
can even do one in slow motion there you
have it like rook to c2
and uh you don't really have a good move
here for an issue your best option is to
just to give up the pawn if you trade
this for example a queen captures a
queen captures non-knight f1 you also
lose the e4 pawn so it doesn't matter
how you play this you will lose the pawn
so anish says okay maybe there's a
better way let's play bishop to a3 now
we are gonna
win back some material uh but still
prague will win his pawn just rook
captures on e2 bishop captures on b for
attacking the rook on f8 but it doesn't
matter rook captures an e1 with check
you have to capture back with the bishop
bishop captures and now comes knight
captures an e4 again similar position to
what we already uh saw in that line at
prague is up upon he has a past a pawn
and now the only question is uh can uh
prague win this anishi is an incredibly
strong player so of course he will put
up a very very stubborn resistance will
proc be able to break through let's see
what happened so d5 uh uh trading of the
uh this spawn uh trying to mess up uh uh
proc spawn structure here knight the d
to c five now with a tempo on the rook
rook the a3 going after the a7 pawn and
now e captures on d5 and this is a a
very very classy move by proc converting
one advantage to another basically
giving up this past pawn for this past
pawn because if you try to defend your
outside pass pawn then there's f3 chases
away the knight wants knight f6 bishop
f2 and now it's already not looking as
great for black
as it did so uh prague continues with
the absolute best move e captures on d5
f3 now chasing away the knight before
recapturing on a7 knight g5 and now uh
rook captures on a7
so still prague has uh the extra d-pawn
and he will now try to set up the the
absolute perfect uh uh position to
escort this pawn down the board so rook
the c8 attack uh sorry rook to c8
defending the knight and now rook to a1
uh here anish wants to put the rook in
front of the pass pawn we have knight g
to e6
uh
and now rook to d1 putting the rook in
front of the pawn attacking the pawn now
pawn to d4 proc starts advancing it
knight to g4 now we have rooked the b8
preparing to infiltrate with the rook
bishop to g3 attacking the rook and rook
to b3 now we have knight to f2 and now
knight to a4 trying to get the perfect
squares for those knights so you can uh
start escorting your pawn king to f1 and
he starts bringing the king into the
game knight to c3 now attacking the rook
and the rook to a1 we have king to h7
and now comes bishop to d6
uh you if you try rook to a seven to go
after the f7 pawn then the idea of
course is rook to b1 the with d to
square covered this is just resigned so
anish can't even move the rook away from
the back rank so bishop to d6 here now
with some ideas of maybe playing bishop
to a3 trying to get some sort of a
barrier here against the past d-pawn but
not knight to d5 we've kinked the g1
king the g6 bringing the king deeper
into the game uh rook to e1 now we have
h5 by prague preparing h4 to completely
[ __ ] the the the white king uh bishop
to e5 and now comes knight to e3 we have
knight to e4 and now pawn to h4 so
taking away pretty much all of the
squares
from from white's king's side knight to
f2 and now knight to c4 putting pressure
on the bishop here and
here prague actually gave anish maybe a
way to get back into the game but it's
very very far-fetched uh here uh if
anish wants to continue playing this he
has to play bishop captures on d4 it's a
temp or temporary peace sacrifice point
being that after knight captures on d4
you have rookie four now the two knights
here are a problem however knight
captures an f3 with check g captures and
not knights to d2 attacking the rook and
the f3 pawn so rook g4 check king to f5
rook capture sun g7 and knight captures
on f3 with check king g2 now you're
gonna play knight to g5 and you get this
position which is uh essentially very
much winning for prague as this knight
can move otherwise you're going to lose
the h3 pawn the f7 pawn is defended the
rook doesn't really have all that many
great moves so you will win this but it
requires a lot of
work so here uh uh but it was maybe the
the best attempt after bishop to h2 uh
now there is no stopping the pawn we
have pawn to d3 by prague 94 and now
point to d2 we have rook to d1
and now rook to d3 preparing knight to
e3 king the f1 uh here uh anisha trying
to say that a knight to e3 doesn't
really work because he has king the e2
but it actually does work but uh okay he
convinced prague but i will show it if
knight e3 check king he two attacking
the rook you just straight knight
captures king captures and now there's
knight to e3 this is the magic move now
of course if king captures knight f1
check picks up the bishop but the real
problem is what if the knight captures
well then the point is knight captures
on g2 and uh you will still win this uh
position as of course knight to f4 once
it lands it goes after the h3 pawn you
will win at least one more pawn and then
the game but you know it looks like a
weird position and especially when you
have little time on the clock and
there's a knight on the board uh things
are never certain and when there are
three nights on the board you just stop
calculating like if you're playing blitz
there are three nights on the board you
have little time you don't calculate
it's impossible to calculate no one can
do it so don't even try it so of course
uh prague goes for the elegant solution
pawn to f5 this requires no calculation
knight to f2 and now rogue back to d7
just keeping everything intact knights
to e3 check of course is still a big
problem so rook to a1 and now knight to
e3 with check king e2 and now knight to
d4 with check saying okay if you capture
an e3 i have knight to c to check then
i'm going to win your rook on a1 so king
captures on d2 but now all sorts of
nasty discoveries are lurking and of
course prague goes for the cleanest one
knight to b3 check just winning the
exchange and now
it's a it's a matter of technique so
here no king captures knight captures on
a1 with knights to d3 and not knight to
c2 with check king to e2 we have knight
d4 check king e3 knights the c to check
and king to e2 so aneesh still not
giving up of course he still will fight
if uh
prague makes one little uh silly move
then anish can bounce back into the game
king to h5 now we have knight to f4 with
check king back to h6 now comes knight
to d3 knight to d4 with chuck king e3
and not knight to e6 so prague has to
uh
uh make everything perfect before he
starts pushing those pawns and of course
the rook will always be stronger than
the bishop so here pawn to f4 by anish
uh rook to a7 and now bishop to g1
trying to get the bishop back into the
game rook to a3 and now king to e2 we
have rook a2 checking the f3 uh king to
h5 now and bishop to e3 so uh putting uh
another defender to the f4 pawn so if uh
it is uh attacked you don't have to
worry about it so rook a3 attacking the
knight not just king back to e2 uh anish
says that this is uh well this is a a a
you know a very reasonable blockade how
are you gonna break through here as you
can see this pawn in this pawn are
preventing the black king from entering
the the game any deeper so here rule b3
prague wastes a move knight to e5 now
and rook to b4
now again i'm putting pressure on this
f4 pawn it's attacked twice so we have
to defend it 93 on each defense and now
rook to a4 we have king to f3 and now
knight to c7 now it's time to bring the
knight to an even more active square uh
bishop to d2 and now uh we have knight
to d5 again the f4 pawn is being
pressured so king the e2 luckily both
your knight and bishop are defending the
f4 pawn now rook to a2 uh just limiting
the movement of uh of anish's pieces
king the e1 and now knights to f6 uh
preparing to activate the knight even
further we have knight to f2 now comes
knight to e4 and your bishop is hanging
and also uh here you just have to uh
trade knight so uh knight captures on e4
f captures on e4 and now
okay now it's a clean rook against the
bishop but still
you give you give an issue one move you
make one silly move and anish will make
this unwinnable for you so here ponte f5
very very clever move by anish uh
keeping that black king uh
stuck on the h file not allowing prox
king to enter the game but uh you don't
need the king actually to win this rook
to b2 king to e2 now comes rook to b5
going after the pawn because it's on a
light square so you don't really have a
way of defending it uh bishop the c3
going after g7 but not proc just shows
how simple it is to win this rook
captures the bishop captures and rook g5
attacking both bishop and pawn so bishop
d4 rook sorry bishop to d4
rook character sun g2 and now king to e3
we rook the g3 check trading down even
further king captures the rook captures
and now king to f4 we have rook to b3
and now bishop to f2 so
if uh anish can somehow eliminate the h
pawn uh then he will be getting a draw
however pawn to h3 bishop to g1 and now
just rook to b2 and he was in this
position on move 81 that anish giri
resigned the game and by winning game
four prague wins the entire match so
prague is now the only person on two out
of two uh as is magnus cross and after
his yesterday's victory over uh han
smoke and niemann uh you've seen that
magnus lost the first one and then he
just crushed neiman in the other three
games but prague defeated alireza very
very convincingly and then
uh he defeated anish so
everyone is very much looking forward to
prague versus magnus but that is only
coming in round five as you guys
probably know so here after rook b2 you
resign there is no defense against h2
you will have to give up your bishop and
then it's just game and of course if you
try king here to keep an eye on the h2
square then of course rook to g2 check
picks up the bishop and that's just it
you're going to capture here rook
captures here and now it's a very very
clean uh win for uh for uh for black
if you want to see it's actually a
forced mate in six a king h2 now rook
anywhere along the g file king h3 rook
to g5 king to h2 king to h4 and now
after king to h1 king the g3 king the g1
only move and now rook anywhere yeah
basically along uh well along the fifth
rank uh
you take away the f1 square from the
king king h1 only move and now rook to
f1 with check it seems pointless to
maybe explain this but if you've ever
had this position in bullet like playing
bullet on leeches or on chess.com and
you have a like three seconds on the
clock and you know yeah your opponent's
king is still in the middle of the board
it's very very important to really know
how to do this in the least amount of
moves possible so you know there are uh
uh situations where this uh you know
understanding this can come in very very
handy uh so after look to b2 anish
resigned and this means that uh prague
has defeated anishigiri so the quote
above the board
definitely uh
stung a bit uh
after anisha posted it on twitter uh but
yeah what are you gonna do uh prague is
amazing uh he is so far unstoppable and
we'll see how he does in round three uh
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it always started the end game
and played the names of india and you
can see that many uh great players are
creating great great victories with the
names of indian defense
i would like to thank ricky hamini
excellent subscriber brendan ward johan
clayson and raymond raphael for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
ftx crypto cup until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day